chris maddox joining us and uh senior
nba writer for sports illustrated
let me start with this schedule mannix
and the importance of the nba coming
back
and playing these games on christmas day
what do you think
i mean the nba understands that
at least for the first quarter of 2021
it's highly unlikely
that we see fans in the stadium so to
maximize their revenue
it's as simple as maximizing their games
and by starting the season
during christmas week you can squeeze in
a 72 game schedule that ends sometime
in late june and that's that's equally
important dan
to this process as well i mean you know
adam silver has said this to me he said
there's others but
like they want to get out next year
before
the start of the scheduled olympics they
don't want to be playing
deep into the summer and competing with
you know swimming and track and field
and things that people watch
during an olympic cycle they want to be
out at a normal time so they can reset
their calendar
going into the 2021-2022 season so by
starting
in late december they can get as many
games as possible
they can fulfill their regional sports
contracts which is important
maximize those national contracts and at
least generate as much revenue as they
possibly can
yeah but the players union is going to
push back on this
yeah the players union has pushed back
on this
will push back on this michelle roberts
her comments this week to the athletic
are in line with everything she said to
other reporters including me i mean i
spoke to her
you know back in august and asked her
about this specific question knowing the
nba
would probably want to get back at some
point december and she said to me
that 2020 just didn't feel like a
realistic possibility and now
here you are uh you know a couple of
months before
a penciled in start date and michelle
roberts uh is saying the
exact same things now understand dan
there are
probably half the teams in the league
that are going to be ready to go
you had eight teams that didn't go to
the bubble that have effectively been
off since march
you've got another half dozen teams that
were done in mid-august i mean there are
teams out there
that are ready for that start but you
can't underestimate
the power of one team and the power of
one player and that's the lakers
and lebron james for this process i mean
i i talked to a player just last night
and he told me he's like if lebron
doesn't want to play we're not playing
so it you know it it probably isn't as
simple as that
but lebron james will have a big
influence in this process
explain to me what the 76ers are going
to look like when they take the floor
this upcoming season now that you bring
in doc rivers you got darrell mori in
there as well
what kind of style and will we have the
same lineup on the floor
oh i mean that's the question right i
mean i think the biggest
the biggest question you have now is
what does this mean for joel embiid and
ben simmons now before daryl mori was
hired
it was almost a mortal lock that you
would see simmons and mb
back with this team together it's
probably likely
that you see simmons embiid back to
start next season
but daryl mori is a free-willing general
manager
who has not been afraid in the past to
shake up his roster
and make significant moves and he's a
general manager that bases a lot of his
philosophies
on analytics and texting with other gm's
they
they kind of said the same thing to me
they were like i wonder what this means
for
for mbean simmons will daryl look to
move one of those guys to create
a more modern nba like embiid is great
simmons despite the fact that he can't
shoot is a great player but they don't
necessarily fit
the modern nba embiid's a low post
presence
simmons a non non three-point shooter
i think it's gonna bear watching in the
next you know month two months
you know how daryl mori views this
roster and if he thinks
that embiid simmons can play together
but also you have stephen silas taking
over
in houston so no maury no dan tony and
what's that mean for the style of the
houston
rockets well first and foremost
steven silas is an excellent coach like
he has been
effectively a coach in waiting for the
better part of the last four or five
years i mean he was considered
strongly for that houston job back in
2016
before mike d'antoni was hired for it
he's been considered strongly for
another
handful of jobs since then he's got a
great background if you go back all the
way to his early days
steph curry and clay thompson were two
players that that worked really well
with him back in golden state
so all that being said the rockets
are an almost impossible coaching job at
this point
i don't think their style of play
changes simply because
it can't like they're not going to go
out there and suddenly have
salary cap space they're not going to be
able to
significantly alter their front court to
add another big man i think steven salas
is going to have his own twist
on some things but in houston
barring a substantial deal involving
james harden
i don't believe you can change the way
they play
significantly enough to make a
difference he's chris mannix sports
illustrated nba senior
writer i'm looking at the clippers there
was a little chatter about maybe chris
paul
coming back rajon rondo
with the clippers what kind of moves can
the clippers make to counter
what's going to be an extremely strong
uh you know west
again next season yeah i mean they're
extremely limited
in what they can do they don't have the
draft capital to make a trade they don't
really have the assets
in general whether it's young players or
otherwise to make a deal what they do
have
are some of these salary exceptions and
you can throw
an exception at rajon rondo and rondo
look his stock hasn't been this high
since he left boston it's as simple as
that i mean the way he played
in the playoffs proving once again he's
on a championship level the clippers
could certainly use something like that
when patrick beverly went down the
playoffs
uh they were really missing something at
that position and rondo can bring
something uh to that slot so i think
you're going to see in los angeles with
the clippers
some nibbling around the fringes a
little bit you'll see maybe a rondo
added or another big man added but
i still think it's more likely than not
that the clippers
dig deep into their pocketbook bring
back you know some of the players they
have as free agents whether it's mantras
harold
or marcus morris or jamichael greene and
try to run this thing back that's kind
of the message dan they were sending
when they brought in uh ty lue i mean ty
lue is an excellent coach
but he's also a coach that can establish
continuity that can help that team
hit the ground running whenever next
season starts so
i think they bring this band largely
back together i couldn't help but think
when lebron was celebrating the title
the confetti is coming down that he was
immediately thinking
who can i get on this roster like what
do we add
and you know there was talk about chris
paul that
can you bring in chris paul do you need
chris paul if lebron just had an
incredible season as your point guard
what do the lakers add or subtract well
i i don't know that there's much room
for them to add or subtract
anything either for largely the same
reasons
that you know the clippers have but the
lakers are in a slightly different
position
in that in the summer of 2021
they could have some pretty significant
salary cap flexibility they could make
some moves
where i believe they'll be right around
30 million dollars
in available cap space depending on what
they do with some of these contracts
uh this offseason uh so their their goal
to make a significant change probably
lies
in the summer of 2021. the chris paul
stuff you gotta remember chris paul
makes like
you know 75 million dollars or whatever
it is like he has a he has one of the
biggest contracts
that's an exaggeration chris that's an
example perhaps okay perhaps it's a
little bit over the top
but but if you're acquiring chris paul
you've got to basically you know gut
your team or deal
a big big name player and really be
willing to roll the dice that's why a
team like milwaukee
still looms i think is the strongest
candidate to extract chris paul
uh from oakland which i believe is going
to happen yeah they could use him
more than anybody and if they had chris
paul this past season i think it would
have been different i think he would
have meant that much to them
and dan you you can you can make it work
in milwaukee you can put together a
combination of eric bledsoe
george hill uh you can sweeten the pot
with a dante di vincenzo or a draft pick
you can make an appealing offer
uh to uh to a team like oklahoma city
and if you're the bucks
it's a no brainer i mean worst case
scenario
you know giannis leaves after next
season you're stuck with one
extra year of a big contract with chris
paul after
the 21 22 season you would wipe the
books basically clean
to start from scratch so there is there
is no
easier move or more of a no-brainer move
to make
than chris paul going to milwaukee
before i let you go i know you
you're not married but you fall in love
a lot when it comes to the nba draft
have you fallen in love with somebody a
little bit
a little bit i'm uh oh god this is
getting recorded uh i'm uh
i'm a big james wiseman guy big james
weisman guy
uh i don't know what to compare him to i
see
a little bit of like david robinson's
game in him from back in the day he's a
hyper athletic seven foot one guy who i
think if he is drafted by golden state
with the number two pick in the draft
he's gonna be a player there for a long
time and he's gonna be effective for
that team
almost immediately i think whether it's
a trade or anthony edwards
that's probably the number one pick but
golden state sitting there at number two
if they don't make a deal i think james
wiseman is their guy and i think he's
uh one of not the best player in this
draft yes mclovin
chris i know you've been in the bubble
for a while have you been there since
1988 have you noticed that uh
centers don't matter anymore athletic
centers
who can run the floor james wiseman
played for penny hardaway
down in memphis and i was talking to
penny about this recently
uh you know penny used to show wiseman
all these tapes of shaq and why isn't
such a young guy
that he viewed shaq as kind of this you
know the lumbering big man we saw with
the lakers he forgot
and you know this dan in the 1990s shaq
ran the floor
shaq was one of the most athletic big
men in the nba and
i think wiseman's got a little bit of
that in him a little bit of the ability
to dominate and run the open floor
what about my guy from uh israel
no you're not now you're getting too
deep in the weeds for me there danny
danny uh avida
no they yeah a deja vu
i'm not even touching that you don't
even not even going this this i know he
is but i don't know enough
to god he looks he he looks great
denny uh addisia i hope we're rolling on
this stuff too not just my
oh no i've already said it before this
okay all right
yeah because but he could wind up being
nicolas
you know nicholas skittish veli could
it was just a tall guy that was it
that that that he could be dragon bender
or mario hazonia or raphael arroyo or
any of the other
international importers or dante exum
dante asks about injury issues that's
why dante exum didn't panic
big opportunity in cleveland this year
oh yeah yeah they're talking about him
uh hey thank you chris i appreciate your
time as always
you got it dan chris mannix